that's not the plan
I mean it's just it's just I feel like
it's crazy to think like Leo's man
because you got locked up was it 2018
yeah and just to think like how the like
all the people got locked up I turned
myself and that was crucial and I had to
turn myself in on a plane ride what the
[__] that's crazy oh I didn't want to go
I already missed the flight
and I'm sitting here in this mansion
with Uzi and all these [__] I'm like
man I'm a rap all right come on no
you're right we're pumping okay Catch Me
If You Can I'd have did it before [__]
this but I was like man let me take care
of this because if it turns out worse
you won't be talking to me today you
know what I'm saying I won't be selling
out the novo two nights in a row and
going on the road you know what I'm
saying that my PO said okay because it's
looking like something
well you were prepared for you know
because you were supposed like your
sentence originally we you were supposed
to be gone for about 10 years right 20.
you still got 20 years right now I'm
gonna Pro I'm on parole but they parole
is like you still got to do the rest of
your time
so I get off parole in 2038. so period
but you're free you're able to cut yeah
just be on on your p's and q's I was
gonna say like I remember talking to TK
about just the amount of music that was
just I got that from Lil Wayne when he
was finna go to jail right I got that
for show from Lil Wayne cause you were I
had heard stories that you were doing
the records and then shooting like back
to back to back to back music videos
yeah it's still hella unreleased videos
I had released a video to substance way
later and then it took off on Tick Tock
I I uh paid whoever was in charge of
that I guess I was doing so much at the
time they never paid the director and
then when I when I found out I shot on
the bread and then we released it
and then Tick Tock took it
tick tock wasn't a thing when you when
you was there
thank you there's this thing where you
just swipe it it just shows you
everything you
left I saw at one point the substance
challenges like them showing their teeth
yeah
if this is what's bringing the Platinum
black shouting [__] I'm witty
[__] whatever the challenge is do
that [__] I love it do you remember or
have an idea of the amount of records
that you cut in case you did have to
well already I ain't gonna lie to you I
already recorded like
hello songs every day of my life any
chance that I got even when I lived in
the trap in the uh Power Hood in the
Campanella park by Road
bro I'm just recording recording your
phone down there
[Music]
okay recording recording recording you
know what I'm saying it's like
I always wanted to be like Lil Wayne or
like at the time like it was some Gucci
[__] going crazy right Jeezy in the
Gucci gangster girls just blew my mind
just at the time we were so into it it
was like watching wrestling or something
goddamn like we was with into every
character we like what's drama doing
with Gucci Mane that he all on the
background
um talking about uh Gucci has been
inducted abducted we like oh [__] and at
the time I didn't even I wasn't
the hugest Gucci fan but I had just got
out of jail my cousin played me that
[__]
and it was just like this [__] didn't
evolved into a superhuman this is around
the time when photo shoot it I'm a star
came out this way Gucci the movie and
bird print 3D came out with DJ Drama and
I was just like
what the [__] like I want to have my
fans indulge like that that's why it was
so important to hurry up and drop when I
came home before I dropped like a real
tape that was just the [__] we could
clear